DAVID SEHR: OK.
Can everybody hear me?
OK, great.
So welcome to the last talk
of the track today.
I'm going to give you an
introduction to Portable
Native Client, or something
we call PNaCl.
My name's David Sehr.
I'm the tech lead of the
Native Client team.
And let's get started.
So since I'm going to assume
that some of you probably
haven't heard about Native
Client, I'm going to give you
a little background
to start with.
I'm going to talk to you about
Native Client, about why
having C++ code running it in
the web is a good idea.
And I'm going to talk to you
about Native Client and how it
makes it something
we can really do.
So I don't think I need to tell
most of you, but there's
a lot of good C++ code
in the world, maybe a
little bad C++ code.
But a lot of good C++ code
out in the world.
People have written a lot of
great applications, things
that take advantage of sort of
the natural advantages of
Native Client.
Things like performance, low
level access to operating
system features, et cetera to
create a really rich and
immersive experience.
These sorts of applications
would be great if we could
bring them into the web.
But the problem is you really
can't bring them to the web as
they are because it's
not really safe.
Right?
You bring Native Client to the
web, and you open up all the
possibilities that we've all
come to know and hate about
the web, which is insecurity
and all the things that can
come from that like having your
identity stolen or whatever.
So what you'd really like to
have, you'd like to be able to
bring Native Client to the web,
but you want a secure
execution environment that can
contain the bad stuff, make
sure that it can't do bad things
to you, while letting
the good stuff run,
which is what we
built with Native Client.
Now Native Client has been a
feature of Chrome since Chrome
version 14, about a year
and a half ago.
We built this for x86.
Had a big launch party
you might have seen.
And it's been a persistent
feature of
Chrome since that time.
About that time, same time
last year as the Samsung
Chromebooks launched that Sundar
already talked about in
his keynote, we brought
Native Client to ARM.
And since that time, we've been
bringing native code to
the web with performance 90ish
percent on x8632 and 80ish
percent of native code
performance on x8664 at ARM.
So you can build the cool
applications that you've
always built in native code
but bring them to the web.
So when we started doing Native
Client, we built a few
applications, we ported a few
things and said, we'd really
like to showcase what are the
cool things that people can do
with Native Client.
And we continue to do this.
I've got a group of people that
work with me that are
continually porting a few
applications and saying,
here's something that shows
off a new possibility, say
vector instructions or some
other feature that we'd like
to show off.
And we think there's some
amazing potential shown here.
And we're not alone.
Over the last year and a half
or so, over 30 applications,
30 games have imported
Native Client.
And you can go to the Chrome
Web Store, and you can
download a bunch of the titles
that I've shown here plus a
bunch more.
So 30 plus games.
And more recently applications
that are
probably not in that category.
Things like productivity
applications, applications to
do secure shell accesses, or
remote desktop viewers for
Native Client.
So there are lots of other
things outside of games that
were also bringing.
Things, for instance, with
Chrome RDP and with SSH, it's
the cryptography performance
that we can bring with native
code opens up a new class
of applications as well.
So lots of applications
have come.
We think the potential has been
seen by a lot of people.
And also people out there have
been doing these great
applications and seeing the
performance that we provide.
So you probably are asking
yourself, if you haven't done
this before, how do I build a
Native Client application?
Well, it's a native compilation
basically as
you've always done.
You take your C++ source code.
In this case, use a
custom compiler.
I have a compiler based off
the GCC tool chain.
And you build something
called a nexe.
And that's a native
ELF binary.
And it's portable across
operating systems.
It runs on Windows, Linux,
Mac, Chrome OS.
But it's restricted to a
particular instruction set
architecture, to x86,
32, or 64, or ARM.
So actually, if you want to
bring the full experience to
the full range of Chrome
platforms, you'll use a set of
custom compilers, you'll
build a set of nexes.
And that will be the
starting point.
You'll add something we call a
manifest file, or NMF file.
And then, along with that,
you'll build a web page.
And the web page will
use an embed tag.
And this embed tag tells where
to find the manifest file and
basically that this is going to
be a Native Client enabled
application.
And with that, you have a
Native Client enabled
application.
So this is what the developer
needs to do to build an
application.
What does the user see when he
surfs to a page that's Native
Client enabled?
Well first of all, we need to
talk about the manifest file.
We talked about the manifest
file before.
The manifest file serves
several purposes.
But the major purpose of the
manifest file is to tell the
browser where to
find resources.
So where to find resources can
be a lot more than just this
in the case of dynamic linking
and some other things.
But you at least need to say
where to find the Native
Client executables.
And you need to have an entry
in this manifest file for
every one of those executables
that you provide.
So that's basically for one
target the Native Client
version of your application
is going to run on.
You'll need one entry in this
manifest JSON dictionary.
And that's going to tell for
which ISA where to find the
native find executable.
So back to the user.
When the user points a browser
at a Native Client enabled web
page, the browser sees that
embed tags and says, ah.
Native Client.
I'll need to do something
with that.
It will load the manifest and
say, I'm running on an x86 64.
So I need to find my resource
in this particular location.
Once it's found that nexe, then
it loads the nexe and
puts it in something we call
the Native Client process.
The Native Client process is a
key part of the whole security
story that we've built with
the Native Client System.
The Native Client System is
built around a technique
called software fault
isolation.
The software fault isolation
is a scheme for basically
analyzing and ensuring that the
nexe doesn't contain any
forbidden instructions,
typically those are the ones
that allow direct native
access to the operating
system, and that furthermore, it
behaves itself with regard
to control flow.
That is it can't run any
instructions that
I didn't look at.
And data flow, that it can't
touch other memory in the
browser or even in the Native
Client process that I'm
looking at here.
So it can't look at your
cookies, or look at your SSL
keys, or things like that.
It can only look at the memory
that the software fault
isolation sandbox allows
it to talk to.
So once of validator has scanned
the nexe and has
confirmed those properties hold,
then execution of that
executable can start.
So once the execution of the
nexe starts, again you still
cannot have raw unfiltered
access to the operating system
because that's where the root of
the security discussions we
talked about before is.
So any time the Native Client
executable needs to do an
operating system service, say to
load an URL, or to talk in
a socket, or read a file.
It's going to talk to something
we call the Native
Client runtime.
Now I like to use shorter
phrases than Native Client.
So I'll say NaCl quite
a bit here.
You'll hear me say that
several times.
So the NaCl run time actually
is what the executable
interfaces with.
And the NaCl runtime is
responsible for checking that
the executable has the privilege
to do the things
that it's requesting to do.
And if not, it can always
abort the execution.
So with this in place--
so the executable has
been scanned.
The Native Client runtime is
monitoring to make sure that
only secure accesses are made.
You've got a process
that's running.
And it's safe.
And you've got a browser.
But they're not talking
to each other.
So how do we make them
talk to each other?
Native Client executables are
going to be plug ins.
So the web page that we talked
about before created embed
tag, which is the classic way
of loading a plug in.
In this case, this is an
out of process plug in.
It's something that's going to
run in the secure environment
we created.
And it's going to talk to the
browser via something we call
PPAPI, or Pepper.
And PPAPI is a rich interface,
having 2D, and 3D, and audio,
and video, and other
things like that.
But the simplest of interfaces
is you just start a plug-in.
And you can postMessage back and
forth between your plug-in
and your page.
And with that, the plug-in
becomes an extension of the
browser's capabilities.
So I think you can see
the potential.
Now we've brought native code.
We made it run securely.
We run it in this environment.
And we can interface with the
web browser to do cool things.
So there are a couple
limitations yet.
We didn't want to bring native
instruction set architectures
as part of the web platform.
Why not?
Well, any time you list off
the set of instruction set
architectures, there's always
one more that you didn't list.
And what do you do for that?
Well, there won't be an entry
in everybody's manifest.
There won't be support
for that.
And this will cause lots
of user confusion.
And there are also security
reasons about this.
The very low level access is to
instructions cause issues
that I'd be glad to talk with
other people about offline, if
you actually allow them
in the open web.
So we didn't want ISAs in
the open web platform.
But we really do see there's
tremendous potential to this.
There's great performance.
There's the ability to create
these applications in the web.
And we wanted people
to get at them.
So we made Native Client
executables available through
the Chrome Web Store.
And so you can go to the
Chrome Web Store.
And it just so happens that at
the top of that page is Don't
Starve, which just so happens
to be a Native Client based
application.
But you see any the 30 games
that I talked about before are
in the Chrome Web Store.
Or if you're wanting to develop
for yourself, there's
a flag which you can toggle that
will little allow you to
run things yourself.
But by default, we have
limited Native Client
execution to running out
of the web store.
So we're done, right?
We brought C++, native
applications.
We run them in Chrome.
And they're deployed
in the web.
What else could there be?
Well, we said we really didn't
want native ISAs in the web.
So what we'd really like to have
is something that wasn't
a native ISA, that you could
package up on your website,
download, and have it become
something in the native ISA so
that it can run on
your platform.
So that's what brings us to
Portable Native Client.
So Portable Native Client, so
we talk a little bit about
this in the Native Client
introduction.
It impinges on the cycle
all the way from the
developer to the user.
So the developer, and the
distribution, and the user.
I'll talk about those starting
with the developer.
So you as a developer start--
you probably already have a C++
application, maybe it runs
on a typical 32-bit machine, a
typical 32-bit machine might
be a little endian, might
be big endian.
But I think for the most
part, things are
little endian nowadays.
And you want to make it so
that it runs on all those
platforms you had before,
that is Windows, Linux,
Macintosh, Chrome OS.
But you want it to run across
all the instructions and
architectures as well.
So you've got this
cool application.
Say in this case, it's this
secure shell thing that we
were talking about before, just
chosen as an example.
And this is also kind of
interesting because in the
secure shell case, as opposed
to a game, which typically
will put up a 2D screen and
manipulate it all directly in
NaCl, the UI in my secure shell
application is done in
JavaScript.
So it's an example of I'm doing
a cryptography in the
Native Client executable, in
the UI, in JavaScript.
So it's a really different sort
of model and one that's
doing a lot of postMessage
back and forth.
So you'd like to bring
that to the web.
So the development cycle looks
a lot the same as it did for
Native Client.
The development cycle starts
when you take your code, you
use of custom compiler.
In this case is PNaCl Clang or
PNaCl Clang++, to bring, to
compile, the application
to an executable.
Now this case-- so PNaCl Clang
is based, as you might guess
from the name Clang for
those of you that are
familiar with LLVM.
It's based on the LLVM
set of tools.
OK.
So the executable that's
produced is no longer and ISA
executable.
It's an LLVM bit code, or what
we call a PNaCl bit code.
With some simplifications and
with some versioning for
making it backward compatible
across a
longer set of lifetimes.
But it's essentially
LLVM bit code.
You again pair that up with a
manifest and a bit tag and
build your web page
as you did before.
And you get the cool experience
that the user wants.
So this was the developer
side.
What's the user going to see?
Well, back to the
manifest again.
Instead of, previously remember
we had one line for
each of the ISAs that were
supported by the application.
Instead of that, we
just have one.
And the one says
it's portable.
You still have to say
where to find it.
That's an URL.
And there's one other little
gadget I'll tell you about
here a little later.
But the developer, when he put
that up, can say, where to
find the performance setting.
And so basically this will
be a trade off between
translation time and full
bore performance.
So the user, when he start
things up, the browser sees
again the embed tag.
It looks at the manifest file.
And it sees there's a
portable executable.
And this time, instead of
immediately starting the
Native Client process, it has to
start something called the
translator.
Now the translator has the
responsibility of taking it
from this portable executable
format and producing the ISA
specific executable that
runs on the platform.
I'm still on an x86 64.
So it produces a nexe.
Once it's produced that nexe,
it again passes that to the
Native Client process that it
creates because we've already
shown that we know how to run
native code securely.
So once it's translated, it runs
the same way as it always
has in NaCl.
So what's more, the translator
is more than just a
compiler back end.
It's more than just the part
that takes the bit code and
produces native code.
The translator's responsible for
taking basically the pexe.
And the first thing it does is
see, do I already have a
translation for that?
And we have a translation
cache.
And the translation cache will
keep track of all the times
that we've previously
translated it.
If there is something
there, and voila.
We start the Native
Client process.
And off we go.
If not, we have to start
the translator.
And again, for those of you who
are familiar with LLVM,
this will be familiar.
LLC is the back end of the
LLVM compiler tool chain.
We'll start LLC.
And LLC will stream the
executable down from the web.
So we've changed it to interface
with the web to
actually pull the pexe down.
And while the pexe is being
pulled down, it will be
translating the previous parts
that have been pulled down.
So we dovetail translation
with download.
And it will produce a nexe.
And you might have noticed this
is running on a Native
Client process.
This is to provide additional
security from a tax where if
somebody puts on a malicious
page a pexe that tries to own
the translator.
In previous situations, there
have been language
environments that had jets
that were exploited by
unscrupulous pages
to do things.
And this is an additional
level of secure
execution for PNaCl.
So once we have the nexe,
they put it in the
cache, and off we go.
So you're probably asking
yourself, this guy's up here
talking about all this
compiler stuff.
I think it's really cool.
We've got compilers, we've got
caches, we've got Native
Client executables.
And I'd love to talk
to you about that.
But you're asking yourself,
how do I use it?
Well, I have some good news for
those of you chomping at
the bit to get using it.
We have a developer
preview in Chrome.
Developer preview is in Chrome
29, actually it's in canary as
we speak, going to dev channel
I don't know what exactly the
dates are but within
a few days I hope.
So there's a flag.
You can go to About Flags.
And you can look for Portable
Native Client.
You can toggle the flag.
Toggle the flag.
Go to the Chrome Web Store.
Find our Portable Native
Client examples.
And you can try it
out yourself.
And here, in a couple of minutes
I'll show you some of
that running.
You can see it for yourself.
What we're really
after, though--
this is an early preview.
Things may be changing.
We're looking for
your feedback.
What did you see for
translation time?
What did you see for the
performance that we
delivered for you?
What did you see about the
executable sizes, et cetera
that you might want
to play with?
We want you to give us feedback
on what you observe
at gonacl.com.
And that's still a
work in progress.
We've put up some Portable
Native Client stuff that's
just very, very much
in the beginning.
But we're going to be adding
more as we go along.
But the things we do
already have--
we do have an SDK for this.
And it just so happens, it's
already part of the Native
Client SDK.
If you've downloaded the more
recent Native Client SDKs, so
you pick the 29 SDK.
You have the compiler, the
debugger, the libraries that
will build Portable Native
Client applications for you.
And also the NaCl port stuff,
which has recently become part
of our SDK story.
So you can see there's a bunch
of libraries there that we
have ported.
And so you can build
applications with a lot of
these things as well.
And you're probably asking
yourself so porting libraries.
Why did you have to
port libraries?
This is a compiler tool chain.
Shouldn't I just be able to
compile anything just by
changing my cc variable
in my make file?
Well, there's a little more to
it than that because it's
native code.
It's running in the
web browser.
We need secure APIs for
doing these plug ins.
So where your native application
might have used
message queues or event
registration mechanisms that
the operating system provides.
Now, your application is going
to be talking to the browser
to get those kinds
of event streams.
Furthermore, where you might
have gotten a hardware device
context, the H wind or whatever
to scribble your 2D
applications output into, now
you're going to have to change
those to use secure interfaces
that actually interface with
the browser.
And last, then, of course,
unfiltered file access is not
going to be OK.
So you'll have to do some
work to actually make
file accesses work.
And we have examples of this in
our SDK that you can work
from to start with.
We have a very vibrant developer
discussion list.
And you could join that.
Or last year, a couple of my
good friends were here.
That's Colt and Noel.
And they gave a talk about
porting a Native Client
application in 60 minutes.
So they took an application,
took it from a running native
application on Windows, used
some of the tools that I'm
showing down here
at the bottom.
They used the visual studio
integration that we have.
They used the debugger
that we have.
And they showed how to take it
step by step through this long
sequence of steps here, most
of which is about just
building things to be
PPAPI compliant.
And that's where you're going to
spend most of your time as
you port an application to
Native Client is the PPAPI
translation.
And since we provide threads
in these environments,
particularly converting threads
from one thread
package to P threads can
be a challenging
part of that equation.
So there will take some
time in porting.
But once you've got it ported,
then you have a Native Client
application.
So what does it take to bring
a Portable Native Client
application?
Really one more step.
That one more step is that you
need to remove assembly code.
As I said before, these
are portable.
They're not tied to a particular
instruction set
architecture.
So having assembly code
just violates
portability on its very face.
So you have to remove
the assembly code.
But that's pretty much
the only thing
that you have to have.
I need to take a little step
back and say, we're bringing
native binaries to the web.
We're bringing large, immersive
high performance
applications to the web.
These may not be small.
So one of the web design
principles that you'll need to
be aware of in doing this--
now there are many versions
of this sort of thing.
But it has to do with the
StartUp Experience.
That when you surf to that
page, the user is sitting
there waiting, waiting, and
waiting while you download an
application.
Be that in nexe, or a large
JavaScript file, or a pexe, it
is something that the user wants
to be aware of something
going on, wants to be aware of
and be able to deal with as
part of the application
experience.
So when I surf to this SSH page,
the translator's going
to kick off for us.
Now I said that we're going
to stream translation.
So the download time
and the translation
time are largely overlap.
But there will be a small
addition to the download time
to do the translation.
So we provide you with
progress events.
Now the progress events will
be able to tell you in the
JavaScript, I'm making
progress.
I've got this much of the
code actually compiled.
And you can put a progress
bar at the top of your
application.
And I'll show you
that in a little
second here, an example.
So that's one thing
you can do.
Another thing you can do is
think about your application
architecture a little bit.
A lot of those examples I
showed you awhile ago of
things that people have done,
cool things that people have
done with Native Client
were games.
And games tend to have this
property that you have maybe a
medium to large application and
a huge bunch of assets.
You have a lot of 3D textures,
and game areas, et cetera that
you want to download.
So if your application
architecture says, I'm going
to have the executable actually
slurp down the
assets, then in a system where
you're pulling down a large
executable, translating it,
and then having to have it
start running before you start
pulling any assets down, it's
going to be awhile before you
actually get to useful work
that the user can experience.
Maybe if your application has
a static asset list that you
can know ahead of time.
Say it has got a few animals
for your games that
you want to put up.
And you know those
ahead of time.
Maybe a better way to do it is
to have the JavaScript request
those assets, put them in a
local HTML file system, and
then let Native Client open
the local HTML file system
afterwards.
This gives you the ability
that the assets are being
download while the translation's
happening and
maybe even dovetailing with some
of the download of the
pexe itself and gets you to
useful work in the game or the
application at large faster.
Lastly, I told you I had that
fiddle in there, that one
extra entry in the
manifest file.
And that was to control what we
called optimization level.
I told you before that pexe to
nexe translation is actually
the back end of a compiler.
So there is some amount of
optimization that still
happens in that part
of the compiler.
Such things as registrar
allocation and high
performance scheduling can
take some extra time and
produce some extra
performance.
So we provide the developer with
the ability to specify, I
want low optimization, which
gives you a faster translation
time, and about 50% of
native performance.
Or you can request higher
optimization levels, take a
translation time slow down and
get a much higher performance,
the 80 plus percent of native
code performance.
So these are the things that
the developer can do to try
and improve the user
experience.
So look at concrete about
the translation rates.
So since we're adding
translation, which was
something that was not there in
Native Client, we have to
talk about that just
a little bit.
So as you can see on x86,
we're doing about 750
kilobytes a second, which will
about keep up with the average
American's DSL sort
of connection.
I think the average American's
bandwidth is about what six
megabits a second
or so nowadays.
So we can keep up with that.
So we think that it's reasonably
balanced against
that at the moment.
ARM.
It's a little earlier
in the process.
And we are seeing a lower number
for ARM, partly because
the processors aren't quite as
beefy but also because we know
there are some features of the
ARM translator that we haven't
brought to bear that are going
to speed our translation
considerably.
And then if you want optimize
code, as I said you want more
optimize code, two to three
times sort of slow downs but
with the considerably higher
performance that you get for
it as well.
Performance.
I already said, what
was the performance
number that you see?
Well, we've done a
few benchmarks.
We're going to do a lot more.
We're still in the process of
gathering a lot of benchmarks.
But the Box2D benchmarks at O0,
we're seeing about 55% of
native performance.
And at O2 we're seeing 85%.
For SPEC about 50 and more
like 90% of native
performance.
SPEC is a kind of a standard
platform CPU intensive
benchmark suite.
So we think this is a
pretty good start.
We have a lot of additional
optimization work that we're
going to be doing and a lot of
additional translation time
performance changes
we're working on.
It should be emphasized that the
translation stuff that I
just talked about a second
ago, that's still single
threaded translation for us.
So we haven't done
multi-threaded
translation yet here.
So I talked about
the developer.
I talked about the user.
So how does the user get the
cool application that the
developer built in PNaCl?
Instead of putting it in the
Chrome Web Store as we did
with NaCl, it's going
to be in the web.
You put it up on your favorite
Apache server or whatever your
server of choice happens
to be, it's going
to be on the web.
So let's talk a little bit about
applications actually
running in the web.
So this is the PNaCl examples
extension that I talked to you
about before.
And this is running one of the
benchmarks, or the examples
that's there.
This is to start our favorite
spinning cube from the demo
from last year.
And you can see there's
a little bit of a
pause in the beginning.
That's the translation time
and the download from the
local machine.
That's the first time
experience.
And after the first time, it
pulls it from the cache, it
just starts.
And even the start up time is
improving because we're doing
some Native Client improvements
actually that'll
reduce the overhead of
validation, which you can
still occasionally see.
So you can see it's not
a terribly long
pause to start with.
But it gets even better
on the second time.
Here's a little bigger
application.
This is Bullet Physics.
And you could see there's our
progress meter going.
And we're done.
And there go our 500
cylinders falling.
And here it is on
the second time.
You see the progress meter
move so fast you
couldn't even see it.
And we're ready to go.
Lastly, if you build without
optimization, you can see the
progress bar chugs a little
faster and gets you visually
pretty close looking
performance.
So that's the O level
translation that I talked
about before.
That versus-- this was O0.
The previous one I showed
you on cache was O2.
So hopefully, you've
seen there's some
real potential here.
We're really excited
about this.
We think this is going to bring
us the ability to really
put some cool stuff
in the web.
Really immersive for high
performance native
applications on the web.
So we're working really hard now
on bringing that out into
the market.
We're planning for a launch.
We're working hard
for a launch.
And we're going to bring all
the instructions and
architectures that you had with
Native Client for the
first launch.
We're going to have threads
and atomics of day one as
we've always had with
Native Client.
And as I said before, we'll have
the SDK full of all the
tools that you've come
to know and love.
The Windows Visual Studio work
is still sort of ongoing.
That may be a little later.
But for the most part, you'll
have all the tools that you
had with Native Client,
especially the debugger.
This was one of the things that
we're very proud that we
have added recently
to the Native
Client Development Suite.
Unfortunately, for the first
release, we've had to
defeature SIMD instructions and
C++ Exception Handling.
These are the two things that
we really wish we could have
delivered in the first version
but I think we're probably not
going to make.
So we have a first update
already sort of in the works.
And the first update provides
one of its big benefits will
bring SIMD instructions.
For a broad class of SIMD
instructions, things like four
wide 32-bit float additions,
and multiplications, and
places that sort of strike
the sweet spot in these
applications.
We think we can do
those in SIMD.
So our first update
will have that.
And in the second update, we'll
hopefully bring C++
exception handling and
resolve that issue.
A couple of things to mention
are that dynamic linking
support and JIT support are
sort of longer term issues
we're working on.
We're very interested in getting
those up and going
because some of our
games have used--
JITing especially.
We have some ideas.
But those are longer term.
So the user side.
So the user experience, we're
going to have translation
caching from day one.
We're going to have optimization
level control so
the user can say whether you
want that splash screen to be
compiled quickly and up in front
of them or whether you
want your physics engine
to provide the utmost
performance.
And we're also going to give
the progress events so that
you can build UIs that tell
the user what's going on.
And I said before,
we don't have
multicore translation yet.
But the guys in the team
are all chomping at
the bit to do this.
So at some point in the not too
distant future after that,
we're going to have multicore
translation.
So we also have some ideas for
the O0 side for some really
fast O0 code generation.
And we're looking into that.
And we're not quite
certain when that
would probably intercept.
But that's also something we're
considering [INAUDIBLE]
fairly soon.
So let's sum up.
Native code.
It's run securely in Chrome
and the open web.
80 plus percent of native
performance.
85, 90 even some of
those examples.
You could try it right now in
Chrome 29 Canary hopefully dev
channel within a few days.
And we're shooting for Chrome
30 as our launch.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID SEHR: Questions?
If you want to step up to the
microphone for questions?
AUDIENCE: So I had
a quick question.
And maybe, I'm not sure if it's
a dumb question or not.
But it seems as though you've
built an abstraction layer
that allows me to write native
code and build it to LLVM.
And then, you can then translate
the LLVM on the
browser as you demonstrated.
And the translated
code is cached.
So my question is let's say if
I build an application that's
really successful, and millions
of people all over
the world download it, millions
the world are going to be
compiling it and translating
this the same way.
Why is this not done on the
server side, or even why can't
I do this as a developer
and sort of do a cross
compilation?
DAVID SEHR: OK.
So that's an excellent
question.
So the question is why--
so millions of people--
you think of millions
of watts spent on
translation let's say.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], right?
DAVID SEHR: Yes.
It's millions of seconds of
people's lives spent in this
thing, perhaps.
Yeah, it's an excellent
question.
So this is for a variety
of reasons.
So doing the translation
actually on the platform
provides the ability to take
advantage of the specific,
particular platform we're
talking about.
So I buy a latest generation
Intel or
AMD, or ARM, whatever.
And it happens to
have some super
microarchitectural feature.
Translation there would allow
the possibility of optimizing
for that specific user
specific department.
That's one thing we've
always talked about.
But no, in the broad, moving
things up and say, in a place
where I have for instance an
installed step where I get it
through an app store.
Then translation up in the cloud
someplace obviously make
sense or translation caching
it up there someplace.
Even if you're surfing the web,
maybe having a proxy that
can do some translation,
this makes sense.
These are things that we'd like
to investigate further.
And definitely the technology
base we built lends itself to
doing things there.
It's more a question of
deployment and user model that
is the issue at the moment.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So if you look at things that
are deployed today, like
[INAUDIBLE], so sure there
are billions of different
[INAUDIBLE].
But today, it's not
done this way.
If you needed applications
today, [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID SEHR: Right.
Well, I should say also the SSH
application that I showed
there actually is right now
in the Chrome Web Store.
It was built using the
PNaCl tool chain.
But they forced translation
ahead of time and installed it
in the Chrome Web Store.
So that's an option
for you also.
And so this sort of thing is
something we're considering.
It's really like sort of a user
model sort of question
that we're trying to resolve.
I think it's a great idea to
do what you're saying.
But there are questions about
where do you host
this caching mechanism?
Where do you get these
things from?
Definitely.
Excellent question.
Over here?
AUDIENCE: I had a question,
like Dart recently added
support for SIMD instructions?
So how you see Dart and
PNaCl in the future?
DAVID SEHR: Well, I think that
the two are complementary
technologies to start with.
I think that we're really
after taking the C++
application.
I've used C++ as a sort of broad
umbrella for all kinds
of native applications that
might exist out there.
Where Dart is much more targeted
at sort of the web
applications viewed more in
that sort of category.
But if you're asking the
question around the
performance, Dart is still a
language that supports a
richer and more dynamically
typed sort of execution model
than we're targeting
with this.
So we believe there's still a
performance gap between the
way their code runs and the
way native code, which has
been, for instance, fully
devirtualized and targeted
toward a specific set
of polymorphism.
So we think there's a
performance gap that would
move toward the sort of the
higher end of as opposed to
Dart or JavaScript today.
The SIMD instruction
thing is sort of--
we're going to get SIMD
instructions.
But then, they having SIMD
instructions, of course, moves
them closer to us.
But there's still a performance
gap there, I believe.
Over here to the left?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so having
developed at the native layer
for Android, I can really
appreciate this.
So you mentioned there's going
to be no support for assembly.
Are you going to provide some
kind of hint so that we can,
for example, kind of hint for
the-- to provide some cues for
the SIMD compiler.
We've seen tremendous use
of the ARM7 NEON.
DAVID SEHR: The SIMD instruction
stuff in
particular.
So the likeliest thing is
a set of intrinsics.
So we're going to have a set
of intrinsic functions that
you call and say, I want to do a
four wide multiplier, a four
wide add, or whatever.
And you'll use some
data types.
LLVM has some of this stuff for
Intel in particular, for
NEON in particular.
But there's no sort of common
way to express it.
Now for the specific things, say
I want to do a horizontal
summation, which only some
platforms support.
Or I want to do some sort of
transcendental or something
that maybe somebody's vector
instructions support.
That kind of discussion we've
had a few times internally.
Maybe we'd like to provide some
way to key CPU id and to
say I'd like this version to run
with this class of CPU and
then have maybe some platform
specific intrinsics.
But that's a very early
discussion.
And we haven't really gotten
very far with it.
We rightfully recognize, for
instance, their instructions
to do AES encoding better on
some Intel and AMD parts.
We'd like to be able to
get to those things.
And it's really hard
to do that with a
portable intrinsic today.
But yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You say you're
using LLVM for this.
Up to now, the intermediate
language in the LLVM, that was
an intermediate step in their
tool change, which means that
they can upgrade
it, add to it.
And you are making it a
persistent thing in a file all
over the world on servers.
DAVID SEHR: Yep.
That's another excellent
question.
AUDIENCE: How is that
going to work?
DAVID SEHR: How are we going
to make it persistent when
it's really a compiler
intermediate representation.
So there was a nice discussion
on the LLVM mailing list--
I don't know, a year and a half
ago or so-- where it was
exactly that statement,
LLVM as a compiler IR.
So we have been working very
hard recently on simplifying.
I kind of obliquely said this
earlier, simplifying LLVM IR.
So there are some complicated
things, complicated
instruction patterns that seem
to raise the risk of changes
happening, attributes on
functions, attributes on
variables, which have just gone
through major morphs.
These are things that we're
severely restricting those
down to just a small set that
we believe we can support.
We've also cut the readers and
writers of LLVM IR off.
We're going to keep frozen
versions of those that will
allow us to translate into the
more recent versions that we
use for the back end.
So the physical writing of it
will always be in the format
that we sort of control.
And with the simplifications,
the get rid of linearizing
addressing and some of the
other things that are, we
think, potentially vulnerable
to IR changes.
We've tried to write
those out.
We have a series of passes that
simplified those away and
hopefully reduced the surface of
LLVM IR susceptible change.
AUDIENCE: So what you're saying
is that you're freezing
the intermediate
language, or--
DAVID SEHR: Well, we have
a versioning scheme.
So we can turn the version when
it really diverges too
severely from that.
But we think that we've reduced
the likelihood of it
diverging very severely by
these simplifications.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
DAVID SEHR: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
One is regarding benchmark.
You saw the performance
numbers.
But are the numbers
similar on?
And the second is once Google
Chrome 30 has been raised,
will it support PNaCl
any website?
DAVID SEHR: OK, so with regard
to the ARM question, I don't
have the ARM numbers with
me at the moment.
So traditionally when we run the
ARM numbers, again, we see
numbers that look like the
x86 64 sort of numbers.
So it'd be toward the 80% as
opposed to 90% sort of range
for the high end of
these things.
So I would guess it
would be there.
But I can get those numbers
and ask this on
Native Client Discuss.
And we'll be glad to publish
those things
out there as well.
Now the other question that you
just asked was about will
it be available in the open
web, I believe, right?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
DAVID SEHR: So the intent
is that actually, yes.
It will be available
in the open web.
You can host a site that
has a manifest file
or refers to a pexe.
And you point Chrome at that.
You won't need to have any sort
of install step, or any
sort of flags, or any sort of
web store to get it enabled.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID SEHR: Do I
have more time?
OK.
It looks like we're out
of time, folks.
I'll be over in the chat area
for the next 15 minutes or so.
So feel free to come by.
And we can talk some more.
[APPLAUSE]